when am I going to watch the Ray - but I
can find a movie theater that's close
enough to me and find time to go watch
the movie and then do a video about it
what am I going to do a video on the
wolf among us episode 3 when I can find
time to sit down and play it then I'll
do a video on it what am I gonna do my
Q&A video soon I hope but I make no
promises awesome now sit back and I'll
give you the review you have been
waiting for
heaven is for real so heaven is for real
stars Greg Kinnear he's a preacher he is
a family man he has his family and his
kid gets appendicitis so he has to go
under the knife while he is he sees
which when I saw the trailer for this I
was like all right I like you know life
after death kind of [ __ ] we've all asked
ourselves that what's after this life
what waits for us after we die might be
one of those feel-good movies obviously
it's gonna feel like it was made for TV
but hopefully could be a good
made-for-tv movie not a boring one like
this movie yeah nothing about this movie
gripped me and that irritates me because
it's a movie about the afterlife that
could be cool the afterlife inspires
imagination at least once in every human
being this movie inspired no imagination
with me and that makes me feel like it
wasted my time yeah it does kind of play
on the fact words like wool is the kid
making it up or did he see something
that didn't actually happen or did he
actually see heaven you don't really
know maybe it's a mystery but they're
not really play it up enough immediately
I'm like nods [ __ ] because medically
the kid didn't die so I'm like well if
he didn't die how do you see heaven at
that point I'm like okay logic says
chemicals in his brain and you know he's
euphoric and he starts seeing [ __ ] Greg
Kinnear his main thing is like he's four
why would he make that up dad's out
there in the world listen kids make [ __ ]
up they do it's just a fact of life
which makes me step out of it I'm like
yeah maybe he liked the attention the
surgery got him she was like I'll take
it a step further one of the main things
when he's telling his dad hey I saw pop
in heaven which is great can hear his
grandfather and he shows him a picture
of him this is in the trailer by the way
Frankie near shows him a picture of this
old guy's like is this Sam he's like now
then he gets a picture of him young he's
like is this him the kids like yeah
that's him for Greg Kinnear he was like
Tiffany my kids not lying but you gotta
really wreck the kid through the coals
man really find out that [ __ ] I take a
few different pictures all different
people like a lineup and one that's
actually the guy I'd be like okay which
one of these people did you see in
heaven don't be like oh is this him cuz
obviously it's him because you're asking
it I really feel bad because I know like
the family believes this and I'm not
saying it didn't happen I'm not saying
the kid in real life because based on
true story didn't see heaven understand
the movie created the space around the
event of your situation is a boring one
in which case you should be pissed too
this movie does have a few feel-good
moments where you're like oh that's
touching and nice and it's the point of
this movie there's
really good moment we're great canoes in
the cemetery talking to this lady I like
that dialogue the very last scene in the
movie I thought that was really
heartfelt and warm and I thought that
was good the actors in the movie did the
functional job Greg Kinnear is clearly
the best actor in the movie the kid
alright here it is kids in movies it's
like this they're not generally good
it's just generally a kid from ETS great
I mean the kid from looper you know the
strong enough kid this kid in this movie
is not that kid even the generic
soundtrack irritated me and that
irritates me that it irritated me
because I listen to music in movies good
music really it sinks it's claws in you
it helps you feel the emotion this is
like generic music from Beethoven I
don't mean Beethoven the guy me like
Beethoven the dog movie that boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom
you're like why the what is this it's
functional for what it's going for is
one of those movies that they're going
to show it like Sunday schools it's not
as compelling as a movie about the
afterlife should be even if you're a
spiritual person that this movies trying
to go for you gotta admit this movie
you're not gonna remember t-minus one
day yep already forgot however I really
want a googol life after death accounts
and start researching that [ __ ] because
that is compelling movies not though so
the afterlife do you believe in the
afterlife or if not I mean it doesn't
have to be clouds and [ __ ] like that
just what do you believe is after this
life whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more